[Music]
all right thank you for having me it's a
real pleasure being here the title of my
thesis is called causal inference for
social and engineering systems so the
key framing question that kind of
motivates us all of this work is a very
simple one so what will happen to y if
we do a
why some outcome of interest and a is
some action that we can take
and many interesting questions across a
variety of fields can be posed in that
simple way for example healthcare you
could ask what will happen to a
patient's health they're given a new
drug patient's health is the outcome of
interest and the drug is the action that
they could take in policy making you'll
ask for example what will happen the
number of covet 19 infections let's say
a new social distancing policy is
introduced
or seen engineering which is close um to
my heart and ask all happened to say a
data center's latency of a new
congestion control policy is introduced
and these kinds of questions are clearly
very important across these fields what
do you really need to understand is the
causal effect that a has and why
so how do i go about doing that it's by
bridging two fields one is causal
imprints and econometrics and the other
one being machine learning why because
causal influence and econometrics think
very carefully about how do you do
causal reasoning despite having
unmeasured confounding
that's what we mean when we say
correlation doesn't call causation it's
really confounding
there's a variety of very beautiful
frameworks that come out of it for
example instrumental variables
regression discontinuities different
differences and all of them what they're
doing is looking for natural experiments
that are happening all around the world
to learn these causal relationships
but generally the estimators that come
out of it have been designed for small
economic data sets
on the other hand we have machine
learning which thinks very carefully
about prediction with modern data steps
it can be high dimensional noisy and
sparse and many frameworks such as high
dimensional aggression kernel methods
neural networks what have you have come
out to deal with that but they're
generally not designed to handle
compounding
and so what i am focused on is to bridge
these fields to get the best out of both
of these worlds
specifically my work's been about
bridging two subfields the one is
synthetic controls which are the core
idea in econometrics it tries to answer
the question of what if an intervention
did not occur what happens if someone
had remained under control
and try to bridge that with matrix
intensive completion which is the core
idea in ee cs stats machine learning
that tries to impute missing data in a
matrix or a tensor
and so my work's been about two parts
the first is called synthetic
interventions which brings ideas from
tensor completion to synthetic controls
in doing so we address the unresolved
problem of counterfactuals in the
presence of interventions within the
synthetic control framework it's laid
out by alberto abadi in his 2020 review
paper
and the second one is causal matrix
completion which now takes ideas
actually from synthetic controls and
brings them to matrix completion in
doing so we try to address the
unresolved problem matrix completion
with missing knotted random data as they
are in my mind shared in 2019 we're at
carnegie mellon let me start with some
work we did in synthetic interventions
so synthetic intervention is really
about how do you do contractual
reasoning via tensor completion for
example say in medicine you're
collecting data of different patients
over time rows will be different
patients columns will be different time
points and different slices would be
different drugs
and each entry of this tensor would be
some health metric of interest for
example say tumor size
because you can obviously only observe
each patient under one drug at a time
you get a very sparse snapshot of this
tensor i get this block sparse tensor
and so meaningful kind of factual
question could be say one of the
patients who had gotten the green drug
had instead gotten the blue drug
that really corresponded filling out the
shaded blue part of the tents on the
right hand side and that's exactly what
synthetic inventions lets you do
for example in engineering you could ask
you have data centers rows would be
different data centers now columns will
again be say different time points and
different slices will be different
congestion control policies you can ask
the question what are data centers who
got the blue congestion control policy
now i said got the green congestion
control policy
now again corresponding just filling out
the shared green part of the tensor the
right hand side
and that's again what synthetic
inventions lets you do
and so you can see that these different
kinds of studies are really
characterized by unique sparsely
patterns and one of the key questions of
causal inference which is estimating
counter factuals really corresponds to
tensor completion
and this is no coincidence there's
really about
these two fields ask the same questions
they just have a different language
for example causal inference many of us
say well it's just a missing data
problem and those of us in ml say well
tensor completion is a missing data
problem
and there's core ideas in both of them
that have a one-to-one mapping for
example the notion of different
experimental and observational studies
they really amount to having different
sparsely patterns in the induced tensor
the notion of estimating counterfactual
potential outcomes that really amounts
to computing specific missing entries of
your tensor and the notion of
confounding which is what plagues causal
imprints you can really write that down
as a problem of missing not a random
data in your tensor okay so there's one
thing i hope to leave you with
conceptually is that there's deep
relationships between these two fields
and what i've been excited about
synthetic interventions is that we've
widely used it across a variety of
social and engineering systems for
example the work i'm probably most proud
of is work we've been doing with tarik
therapeutics which is an alzheimer's
company
so they give us access to their phase 3
clinical trial data that had failed and
cost them around for over two years run
cost almost half a billion dollars
and the average treatment effect of all
the therapies that they tried was
ineffective it was insignificant
and so the question we were exploring
with them was that maybe there was a
subset of patients that the therapy was
effective on
and this is the type of tensor that was
induced here
and what we did is we filled out the
right hand side of the sensor that is
for each patient we created a synthetic
trajectory of what would have happened
to them under every drug
and what we actually found throughout
through um this procedure was that
actually 20 of patients could be
potentially responsive so all was not
lost and this is being now used to guide
the next phase of clinical trials and
they've been so excited about it that we
finally we jointly filed a patent with
their mother i also currently consult
for uber technologies and the question
they had for us was that what would
passenger wait times be if u.s city has
adopted routing policies that have been
used in brazil and again you have this
tensor it's a little bit different now
because you get the staircase patterns
because different cities adopted the pa
the policy at different time points
and again what we found by this kind of
tensor completion perspective was that
larger u.s cities would see the greatest
increase in wait time and because these
kinds of a b tests are run all the time
in uber technologies they're trying to
use the synthetic conventions framework
in their production systems as we speak
they're across user across a variety of
applications including with the poverty
action lab at mit some covert 19 policy
evaluation with caroline ullah we've
been thinking about using the broad and
drug design and with dream 11 which is a
large e-commerce company that thinks
about uh fantasy sports and qriket in
india
and in terms of specific results what
you can show is that this kind of
factual trajectories you get for each
unit under each intervention that's
finite simple consistent with the
true counterfactual trajectory and you
can also prove asymptotic normality
results which lets you produce
confidence intervals the key structure
you need is that the underlying tensor
that's induced is low rank that's really
what lets you share information across
units time and interventions
i'm going to spend a little bit of time
talking about
matrix completion
so matrix completion sometimes get a bad
rap people think it's just
recommendation systems where rows are
users columns items and you want to fill
in the ratings but it's a lot more than
that for example it can encode
regression discontinuity which is
imagine medicare where you get a certain
you get medicare at age 65 that kind of
leads to the staircase pattern or even
say in contextual bandits think of rows
as different states columns of different
actions and each element is being
rewarded for a given state in action
right so the goal across these
applications is computing missing
entries and denoising observed entries
and the impediment to unified approach
is that different applications have very
different sparsely patterns
so our main contribution here is a
unified approach that works across both
empirically and theoretically across
these variety of positive patterns
the algorithm that we propose is called
synthetic nearest neighbors it brings
together synthetic interventions with
nearest neighbors or collaborative
filtering known more colloquially
and the theoretical results we produce
is entry-wise finite sample consistency
and asymptotic normality and in general
most recovery results in matrix
completion and the frobenius dome what
we prove is an entrywise guarantee
so what do i want to do with assignments
one slide on it
i think the one thing that keeps me up
at night nowadays is how do you build
causal simulators for reinforcement
learning we've heard so much about
reinforcement learning over the past day
i think one fundamental assumption
that's being made a lot of the times is
that you have a simulator what is a
simulator it's an oracle that helps you
answer the question what if some agent n
took an action a at state s
what's the next state you need a
simulator that tells you that answer but
to me this is fundamentally a causal
question
so where have we seen the greatest
success of reinforcement learning so far
well it's bought in video games where
you have simulator for free
or it's in places like the open yeah gym
or robotics where you have to
painstakingly build the simulator with
your knowledge of physics
so i think a key challenge the
widespread use of reinforcement learning
is creating such simulators for complex
cyber physical systems say the electric
grid or data centers or health care
policy making
the question i have is can we build
causal simulators for reinforcement
learning using historical data
what i mean by that is offline data by
only gets a historical patient records
of previous state action tuples and
fundamentally you cannot experiment with
your system
and so what i call causal because it
could be observational data that is
there could be a latent confounder that
affects both the state transition
dynamics and the action that's picked
and for those of you who are familiar
with the markup decision process
literature in mdps you normally assume
that the action is still only a function
observed state what makes it a causal
problem is now the action itself can be
a function of unobserved latent state
so two works are done initially on this
one is called per sim which is about
building simulators despite having one
observational trajectory per agent and
on the more theoretical side i've been
thinking about formal analysis of
observational linear dynamical systems
and thank you very much
[Applause]
it seems like in some cases there are
some uh information limits like uh i can
control two different causal
relationships between some number of
variables such that the observations
together are identical um i mean so like
see if
in some sense
that is being captured by the latent
factors that define the tensor
and what we're not trying to estimate is
those latent factors we're going to
identify those so as long as the
different related factors give you the
same outcome it doesn't matter because
we're trying to make it it's up up to
rotational and variance doesn't matter
because our object of study is the
outcome itself not the latent factors
that define the outcome
yeah so when you're doing this kind of
data imputation approach you're using
the low low rankings of the tensor as a
way
choosing what to impute there
but presumably
you still have other choices to make you
can't just use low rank as a way of
choosing between how to
what your sort of inductive bias is so
how do you how do you how do you choose
between different low rank completion
so we don't want to do this global
estimate test in general if you try to
do like uh find me the best low rapid
fit that fits your data
those generally don't work with
estimators the technology is very very
simple it could be missing this pattern
what we're trying to do is a very local
perspective like a nearest table style
thing and then those you actually get
unique answers okay there's only one
answer that you can get in that sense
but
um
nice